[Music]
from your secret friend
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
why's he writing to you
if you
are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
[Music]
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
this guy's crazy
you're part of this too
how am i part of it
you'll see
[Music]
hands up
still
get out of here
[Music]
fear is a tool
but when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
that's a warning
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
oh my god
this is about a king
and river's the match
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
oh take it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
i'm vengeance
what's black
and blue
and dead all over
i got you
[Music]
who's swing
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
my family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything
the riddler
is asking for you
the killer left this for the batman why
is he writing to you
you came
i've been trying to reach you
good there's latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strikes
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend to yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this chest call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruised
[Music]
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know she suffered
delaney
who are you under there
what are you hiding selena don't throw
your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
[Music]
let's get into some trouble
you